Prince Harry his wife Megan and her
mother Doria have been involved in a
near catastrophic car chase involving
Paparazzi photographers this is coming
from a spokesperson for Prince Harry we
do know that Megan and Harry were in New
York last night for an award ceremony at
which Megan was receiving an award we
saw Prince Harry Megan and Megan's
mother on the red carpet and it seems
that leaving that event or sometime
after it there was
um
a Chase it's being called by Prince
Harry's uh spokesperson to chase
involving Paparazzi photographers in
cars Megan was at the women of vision
award in New York last night and so
that's all we're hearing at the moment
it was the couple's first public
appearance since the king's coronation